next up we have developer and web
workers give it up round of applause for
developer how everybody my name is de
Belgard or as my mother gave me name
Bhushan
I guess and I come from Serbia I'm in
Berlin for one month and I work for this
company
it's called smaller and we do online
loans and so I never thought that
working with money is going to be any
kind of fun until I came here so it is
kind of so today we talk about the web
workers it's kind of a tricky topic and
we're done as well because it's already
a 2018 and can you show hands who is
using this table yeah like that so I'm
seeing a front-end engineer and
technical product owner it's mother as I
said I block at double double W
developer.com and the same I use the
same how to say the checker Twitter
handle so let's start this is a bit of a
history already I mean you know I grew
up in the 90s and for me like ten years
ago is always like 1999 so yeah I mean
but ten years ago was like almost this
and before we have this kind of react
and we learn all sorts of like mumbo
jumbo and pretend we needed something in
order to support it and do mm and I
actually happen this revolution that
people don't know so much what they know
but I'm not and it's called read or
better say like just-in-time compiler
and oh man many job interviews you will
secure this question like is JavaScript
compile entre or interpreted and yeah it
is both so then when some nice people
introduce the just-in-time compiler the
like performance of executing JavaScript
really elevated and then in 2013 the
react came as a result of that and also
the result of Facebook's tried to
basically elevate some of the heavy
weight lifting to the user devices which
was very nice from them ok so let's move
on
so why web workers I mean if in this
2009 something somebody introduced the
thing which can which open the door for
likely interior applications and then as
we all know like in computer application
it to be executed in a browser that
means like single stack of execution and
that is basically you know where they
say like JavaScript is a single thread I
mean it's not Java stream that is single
thread it's just the browser that are
single thread kind of so even though
that you just a few people listed hats
and saying that they use the web work is
today we workers as a web workers not
Service Worker and introduced long time
ago and basically what does that mean is
that the browser support is super it's
you can easily use it from me turns over
11 and above but also yeah even though
it introduced this like multi thread
support and it kind of fixes the single
threads on the front end it's still not
twice widely used for a number of
reasons so no matter of the a sink you
can see actually on synchronous nature
of the web api s-- which was also like a
part of common stock and i like you know
all this web where we had like
settimeout xml httprequest and so on and
so on like there are many time that work
as interns me but that's not what it's
real it's just not working
what that means is that some
functionality is like elevated to the
web api and then once is finished is
still wanted to going to like return to
the to the main thread
this single stack of execution so yeah
this is about the browser and uh no
dress because of these cool times that
we live in we can run the JavaScript on
both ends the front and then the back
end and as you can see like in this
visualization it can give you the
information that the web workers are
very well a supported browser and as
they're a part of the web api's they are
not supported in notice what it means
not natively that means that but yeah
because essentially that's called web
workers and the note reyes as itself is
like built so that it's is going to be
in brick in it as a kind of ecosystem on
this single thread as well I'm just yeah
I'm not going to go deep and and talk
about the see libraries that no trespass
roam centered yeah they can't have like
the multi thread stuff but it's not not
Reyes not to Travis Creek
so the synchronous code blocks the
browser I mean sometimes you can
actually go to your browser like
literally for your UI as well not just
the execution of the JavaScript and yeah
it's obvious here everybody knows but
even if you postpone the execution some
population that will not solve your
problem it was just delayed inevitable
you know because if you do some I think
actions and then whatever is returned
you will still for example this is the
usual API call stuff you get your JSON
and then you need to parse it I mean
this bar thing is synchronous it was
always synchronous and asynchronous and
if you have like some huge data set yeah
you can imagine them and hired well
sadly a lot of bad architectural style
projects that ended up doing the weird
things so most of the time what happens
is that people on the back end for any
reason don't want to send you the
appropriate format so you get the data
and what happens is that you need to
parse it sometimes is huge
so that parsing is going to block your
execution of course and then you need to
reorder it or to reformat it and do also
incredibly horrible stuff that I don't
accept anymore luckily and if you want
to use your web workers for that I mean
please don't just come by to your
packing guys and and fix this stuff
don't just patch it up so we came to the
table and when when web workers are in
question the taboo topics are basically
done window object device or the parent
object so in the web workers scope of
execution you cannot success Dom
directly I mean you can still like pass
to the worker whatever you like but you
cannot access it directly and you
shouldn't that's not that's not the
reason why they started to exist of
course there is this like green stuff so
that's the thing that you should do so
in the web worker you can access the
Navigator object of course which can be
useful I intentionally read like code in
red this user agent because even if you
go to the MDM website you will see like
thumbs-up thumbs-down for user agents
which is super you know because I really
hope that now in 2018 people stopped
detecting their devices but user agent
and Gandalf continued not started
continues to detect the features of the
environment and use whatever is
available so in the web worker you can
access the academia XML HTTP request
that's important to know and of course
by then you can you can do all sorts of
like data fetching if needed
but the web worker is not a standalone
thing and basically wheel into one web
worker you can load as many as these sub
workers you need does in like theory you
can go nuts with the dislike horizontal
scaling or key resources
and like doing things in like minion
threads but you don't do it please
because if you there is one
misconception about this you can use
your web workers in order to elevate the
heavy weight lifting but even though
it's not going to block your main stack
of execution it's still going to affect
your device performance because at the
end is just one CPU that does does all
of this stuff so the web worker or the
broker and service worker not the same
so the worker resides in the global
scope that means that you can
instantiate it from within any place and
just by using the new worker new
keyboard on this burglar object or other
method you can have as many workers per
table as you as you want this is very
difference between search work and
worker and it's very well supported and
for the service workers they need to be
registered I mean the service worker one
service organ is two villages that we
have navigator service worker register
and that means that you can just have
one service worker per the domain and
that was the whole idea yeah it's just
like having one service worker the
candles all this stuff which is more
than less just I mean not just but kind
of a proxy for your data and it's heavy
weights lifting in terms of like caching
and stuff and yeah you cannot use the
XML HTTP request within the service
or you can use fetch I mean I don't know
the reason what what I think that it is
it's basically that fetch is like better
because with HD xmlhttprequest you will
need to write a lot of custom article to
consume some libraries in order to do
some simple stuff which just comes
shipped with the fetch and support is
limited so yeah this is basically like
one kind of a phone call because between
the paper main context of execution your
application and the web worker and on
the first iteration of like this
changing the messages I mean before I
start just to say that web workers are
about communication and this is
basically just what they do the API is
very simple and and all the things that
you need to do is to instantly the
object as you see just a sheet of the
worker to post some message to work her
like to provide some data to it and then
on this blue stuff when it says like web
worker this this is actually part which
is written within the worker itself
within this web worker DOJ's file you
actually just wait for a message and
then you do whatever you like with it in
this case you just return some method
which process the data and then on the
main context you just wait for it for
you just have a listener basically it
waits for on from that return back
message and do something with it and
that's it I mean very simple and what
are the use cases yeah this is kind of a
topic for itself because if you want to
move your unresponsive code to the web
worker like don't do it please because
it's just going to our it's just like
putting trash
below how to say the the car but yeah I
mean eventually your wife will come and
then you're screwed so yeah repacking
for data sets more or less always lazy
back-end so don't do it on the front end
place even if you're elevated to some
like application stage redirects topics
whatever and then you do this heavy
stuff within the worker is still
horrible like you just should not do it
and yeah like I said it's going to
affect your UX which is like very
important and I mean the multi-threading
is not about heavy lifting it's just
about not working your main stack so
imagine that you have this ecommerce
solution and you have a button that says
like Add to Cart and then you start some
heavy calculations no matter what it is
one of our colleagues had this use case
where he basically they needed to scan
the QR code and when you scan the QR
code sometimes it can you know just
consume a lot of resources if you want
to do is something we need to process it
and stuff so what I did is that they
thought to put this in a worker because
if you scan this stuff and it needs to
do something which can endanger the user
of your current execution stack and if
you just get stuck on the stack
executing if you click on this button to
add to cart' something a product dead
action will need of course to update
some state and then to just you know
push the changes throughout your
application so when you click to this
like Add to Cart button and this stuff
is going to continue executing in the
background on your stack you will not be
able to do it basically
so in this modern age of like e-commerce
it's not only about having me like
fastest page load time it's also about
never ever have this situation when you
block your execution stack with anything
and yeah at the end basically like if
you want to terminate the worker you can
do just this simple thing work it or
terminate and then you do it from the
main contact context or your application
or you can do like self dot close also
close use this method for the same
purpose okay so this is like the very
simple you like very simple example
it's not fancy in some like react
framework or stuff it's just like pure
JavaScript nothing special so what do we
do here is that the only thing that you
need to think about is this calculate
primes actually I took this method from
the MDM and what does it do it's just
doing some horrible stuff like like
doing basically the random calculations
and yeah it's very horrible so basically
you just want to make your CPU
artificially go crazy and yeah here are
just little on minimal unload I just
waited for four seconds because I wanted
my webpage to be at least at some point
like responsive so if you reload the
page we can like see how it's updates
and then it doesn't I mean I'm still
ticking and nothing happens because the
heavy calculation started and I can do
this and if I'm a user you know I will
just say like oh this doesn't work click
and I will press like ten times in the
nagato spot and then maybe close the
website and then there is no purchase or
stuff so how you can fix it is very easy
and in this case we can just remove this
horrible code and replace it with a
worker
so you basically instantiate a new
worker this method accepts a part and
then you define a message to be posted
to the worker is basically just
of some kind of object and here you just
wait for worker to return you something
simple as that so if you go to our web
page and we reload it you will see that
basically I can click all day long yeah
and it works so I'm not going to lie to
you like there is not a magical answer
on like what what are the use cases for
it and that's one of the reason why
people don't use it is that I mean if
you if you need to use it you're allowed
or maybe you will be wrong by knowing it
because the thing is that most of the
time people if they write a good code it
will not end up in a situation when you
solve it by the water but in some
specific scenarios if we have in mind
the limitation of our smart phones
especially we should consider elevating
something even like the API calls to the
worker because it's all about not
blocking your stack execution and
basically nothing else thank you